hello everyone we are back at the
capablanca Saga at the 1914 tournament
of sankt-petersburg
it's Alexander Alekhine versus Jose rule
capablanca so if you've been following
the capablanca so far kappa blanka alien
have already met also in some feature
group but in 1913 so a year before this
in the sovereign cup where as you
already mentioned to your you know
friends and family capablanca won both
games with the white pieces it was a you
know a clean win and with the black
pieces alien had some chances but in the
end
capablanca prevailed so first capablanca
defeated our enemies of each here in
saint-petersburg
then drew three games and then we have
this very nice game against Asian so
down two points can I let him do
something about that let's check it out
I'll even has the white pieces and he
opens with E for let me just fix that we
have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 so I'll even goes for the
reuleaux PES with d6 the old Chinese
defense although in those days I don't
think it was called the old Chinese
defense maybe just this tiny defense d
4e capture some d4 Knight captures on d4
and Bishop to d7 just defending here and
now Knight to c3 now I didn't of course
isn't interested in trading everything
here for example sorry now that I him
after Knight to c3 couple Blanca could
trade everything here for example Knight
captures on b4 Bishop captures Queen
captures and after Queen captures here I
think we just have a very nicely
centralized queen on d4 although if
you're playing blitz or bullet and you
come up to this position you could offer
the g7 phone as a nice surprise
for example if white captures the Bishop
g7 attacks the Queen Queen g3 and just
keep on developing Castle queenside and
maybe use the semi open G file for some
for some development but okay all rights
a nice idea for bliss simple it may be
but capablanca just develops nice to f6
we have castles and now Bishop to e7 and
here this position has been played
plenty of times even in modern chess and
rook to e1 is the general idea here and
almost 300 games are available in the
database where rook to e1 was played
here
battalion prepared something special for
her but for a couple Blanko he wants to
take him down so nice to f5 and it was I
don't know if this move was played
before in those days
I wasn't able to find that information
but definitely a surprise for kappa
blanka that he has to decide how to
tackle over the board and the couple
Blanca could decide to give up the light
square bishop he could also maybe Castle
and decide to give up the dark square
Bishop for example Queen captures rook
e1 now comes let's say h6 per membership
g5 and after y develops the game
continues one way this game could could
continue but after Knight to f5 kappa
blanka decides to give up the light for
bishop and double aliens pawns here so
what's what's the idea here why did I
let him allow this well it's gonna be
this double f5 pawn will be a nuisance
for a couple Blanca as you'll see we
have castles backup of wonka rook to e1
now developing and now Knight to d7
couple Blanca now wants to put the
bishop on this very strong diagonal
ended the night might come to a 5 might
come to c5 but also might come to b6
depending on what white plays I can take
this opportunity to take this excellent
outpost for his knight on d5 with Bishop
to f6 as planned and now comes c3 alia
Alia can simply blocks off b4 nd for
from a couple of long casts night but
also it's a nice blockade for the bishop
we have nice to b6 couple Blanca wants
to trade nights here and now comes
Knight captures on f6 a couple of longer
doesn't mind giving up the dark square
bishop we have Queen captures on f6 and
now Bishop captures on c6 alia now has
the bishop prepare against to cup of
long has Knights so it might be also
possible to continue with both of the
bishops but iron has a different plan
first the bishop captures pawn captures
and now Queen to f3 Queen to g4 was also
possible with the idea of Bishop to g5
but then h6 comes and well all-in-all
alia who decides for Queen to f3 we have
rook F to e 8 and now rush of the e3
kappa blanka goes c5 limits the the
mobility of this bishop and the now
comes Luke to e2 11 now plans to double
rooks along the e-file rook to e5
Capablanca is interested in doing the
same also pressures de-spawn and a lien
goes rook 81 and now what's happening
here can capablanca capture this f5 pawn
the the answer is no if you play rook
characters on f5 then white wins
instantly now I'll let you pause the
video here and try to figure out what
was aliens idea here for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
it's a very nice back rank mate
and for those who who just wanna enjoy
it so you can see that I come along as
back rank is weak and here Bishop to g5
attacks the Queen and threatens
checkmate so if you capture here then
rook to e8 will lead to checkmate and if
you play something like group to f8 just
you know preventing checkmate then
Bishop captures on f6 is sufficient for
winning the game you have to pick up
White Queen as well but then just Bishop
e7 you attack the rook
after the rook moves let's say Roxy I
said then you go you can even even go
Bishop d8 and threaten another
checkpoint but you can also just capture
the rook you are up a whole rook and of
course you are winning this game but
there was a possibility of capablanca
playing Queen captures on f5 and then
after Queen captures rook captures
Bishop captures on c5 again with the
threat of the back rank mate and then
after the King prevents checkmate you
could remove the Bishop Bishop before
and we would have this position where I
even would have a bishop against the
knight would already have double rooks
along the e-file so white would be
advantageous here and a lien would have
to point islands against kappa blanka
three point islands but Allegan isn't
interested in playing a slightly better
end game against Capablanca
so after rook a to e one sorry
Capablanca is not interested rook 88
couple monka also doubles on the e-file
and here again i would you do you could
trade everything let's say blush up to a
four rook captures rook captures rook
captures Queen captures and then a lien
would be threatening the back rank mate
but then you can just go
six and now you cannot capture due to
Queen captures you would play Bishop h6
again threaten checkmate and then after
Queen e5 you would go into this endgame
Queen captures D captures F captures H
captures where I didn't would once again
have a bishop against tonight with a
would have slightly better pawn
structure but again not something he's
interested in so after Luke 8811 decides
to go for the Queen side weaknesses
which she created when he captured
Bishop captures on c6 11 goes Queen to
b7 and okay now cava Blanca is free to
capture the DF 5 born we have Queen
captures and now Queen captures on c7 we
have Queen to b6 now creating this very
strong rook Queen rook battery something
alien is the famous for and here you
could go g3 or something prepare some
squares for your king but I didn't
decide it's okay to capture yet another
pawn so Queen captures on a7 and here
you see that capablanca is down upon but
he has a lot of pressure along the e
file we have Knight to d5
the idea is Knights the effort to create
threats along the G file so how well I
didn't meet me to this probably the best
course of action would be g3 simply
prevent Knight from coming to f4 and
then after f5 threatening f4 you could
go c4 put the knight back and now you
would most likely have to go to f6
capturing here doesn't really do
anything rope captures you could capture
with the Queen and then after rook
captures D captures you could actually
capture here and then after low captures
you could play this check and pick up
the rope king of seven you could capture
here and then after g6 you would the
black would a white would have to move
the pawn as its attacked you could push
a three and you would get this position
where white is a pawn and you know being
up upon you know Queen opponent game
usually means the game
so after this Knight to d5 move I even
didn't go for this g3 idea even though
okay capturing on e3 was not a forced
line cup of Monica would just go back to
f6 I didn't play the King to f1 and here
he runs into a lot of a lot of problems
couple Blanc immediately goes Knight to
f4
now of course you cannot catch
because of rook captures ani ani to
route 32 defending and here Capablanca
as well we already mentioned if
Capablanca finds one path then he he was
lazy to calculate another one but also
as a reaching move 30 that was the time
control back then you also needed to
play faster so here a couple Blanca play
tonight capture Sun g2 which is a great
move but there is a better one there is
a move that wins instantly which both
capablanca can delay he missed
especially since I get him decided on
this King to have one move instead of g3
so how should a couple Blanca have
continued playing this position again
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this you know elusive idea
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
checker of kings queens c4 is the move
follows if you just want to enjoy it so
yes
King to g1 or you can block with the
rook and lose lose the exchange Kings
you want and only now do you capture
here but now it's it's different when
the Queen is here because now after the
King captures you can go rook g5 check
offer even a look because now after
Bishop captures now the rook controls
the entire efile the Queen is covering
f1 as you can see so here you would just
go Queen g4 check King f1 Queen h3 check
force the king to move back into g1 and
now comes Luke captures anyone the rook
anyone is unguarded and this is
checkmate
so Capablanca did not calculate all this
out and idahe most likely missed it
Capablanca went for a different line
Knight captures on g2 we have King
captures and g2 and now Queen to g4 with
check King to f1 and now comes Queen to
h3 check but now the bishop is on e3 the
e-file is not bla you know cut off from
the white king so alien takes this
opportunity to stroll
his King you know along the back ranks
kingi - now comes rook captures on e3 a
very nice continuation F captures on e3
and now Queen captures on e3 so of
course if you go to f1 you are quickly
getting checkmated
so pink the d1 is the idea with Queen
captures anyone now the material is
balanced Queen to King to c2 and now
comes the Queen to e4 check we have King
to b3 and here again the classic moment
where Capablanca has an opportunity to
enter the game promptly he decides to he
doesn't go for Luke to a which is quite
deadly after the Queen moves you would
push c4 and it's all over
the queen is covering c2 but most likely
a couple Lanka saw that after rook
captures on d6 he cannot capture the
Queen because of this checkmate but it's
not a problem
even if rook captures on d6 kappa blanka
can just play h6 there are no more back
ranked weaknesses and the jae-hoon has
to move the Queen or give up the queen
but capablanca played Queen to c6 first
seemingly now if he's definitely
threatening to trap the Queen or you
know again and go for and go for this c4
check but again he was a he was afraid
to do it I didn't played a four and here
kappa blanka again has the opportunity
to play rook to e8 but he doesn't
because now if rook to e8 the only
defense idea he could have is rook
captures and e6 but now of course you
don't capture and allow of course you
don't capture and allow checkmate but
rather you would go c4 check this is the
idea and now after the King moves you
would go Queen G to check King b1 now
comes Queen to e4 check King to a2 and
now
h6 simply freeing some h7 Square for
your king now the Queen has to move
Queen to d7 you have to guard a four and
now Queen c2 and now rook captures an a4
is the threat and white is lost here for
example Rock a6 you want to you don't
want to allow Luke captures and then
Queen checks because now the Queen would
also after picking up the rook defendi a
for pawn but what you can do is go after
this rook to a6 rook b8 threatened
checkmate and only now after this rogue
b6
you would capture Queen checks now you
would pick up the rook and lose the a4
pawn so Queen captures can be 121 check
King moves and
now queen d5 it's a it's a fairly long
calculation but it's a it's a forced one
so capablanca would have no problems
calculating it and it would have this
end game you were up upon in a queen and
ponen game and especially with such a
nice pawn it would be it would be a
easily winning end game but Capablanca
says i I don't want to calculate he
plays d5 and now a lien really doesn't
have all that much to do there are no
more threats here now the rook there are
no rogue d6 tricks so here I can just
place a 5 and we have Queen b5 checked
by kappa blanka King to a3 and now rook
to b8 and now capablanca doesn't even
care about the d5 pawn of course this
would allow a quick checkmate so King to
a2 we have h6 now making some room again
for the King on h7 a6 by alien getting
that pass born closer and closer but now
comes Queen to b3 check and it was in
this position that Alexander Alekhine
resigned the game why did he resign well
you have to move the king and after the
King moves now of course well I'll let
you decide why he resigned feel free to
pause the video here for the third time
in this video and find the winning idea
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations
you are an excellent player and for
those who just wanna enjoy it show the
Queen is covering all these very nice
squares so look create threatens
checkmate you would have to play rock c2
to prevent it with Roxy 1 but now just
rook e1 check rook blocks and now rocky
2 and now there's no defense you could
prolong the game for a bit for one move
or two but you know it's pointless or
whatever
will you play either block with the
route and Queen captures then Queen
capped or some B - checkmate
it's all oger sir and of course there is
this maybe maybe you think okay why not
Queen b7 but then you just do it this
way rope captures think here and then
you can just deliver checkmate we are
twin-tuition a - also a possibility but
after Queen to b3 are you can decided
not to wait and a very nice victory for
josé raúl capablanca so a very nice
victory against nimzowitsch in round 1
then 3 draws one almost away
against world champion in manual ask her
but you know there's a lot at stake when
you play the world champion so I think
all in all
maybe Capablanca was interested happy
with a draw but as he didn't include
that game in any of his books one might
also think that you know not really sure
you can see that Capablanca could have
ended this game a lot sooner a few times
you know before this move thirty five
but he just played moves that he knew
that we're winning eventually you know
maybe not the tire himself out but he
also said that he wasn't feeling all
that great before the tournament so
maybe that also took its toll it's hard
to say but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Jim Bob distal Otto Benjamin
Forbes Brian calling a Miller finish
which and David Casas for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous videos your thing called
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content definitely continuing the
sankt-petersburg tournament and also
we're gonna check up on some legal games
and of course your own hash tag
suggestions I think you all and I will
see you soon